[Music]
don't like myself don't like my job
stress with the kids and the wife
life just sucks did your parents beat
you up as a kid or neglect you or leave
you on the outside yeah okay that sucks
and they shouldn't have done that your
wife doesn't deserve that exact same
treatment that was done to you does she
no
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
delona's show
making magic
here on the youtubes and the podcasts
and the internet
so glad that you joined us for the
greatest
health and wellness mental health
relationship podcast ever
in the history of uh the digital medium
which is a very short history a very
short convoluted messy history so glad
that you're with us hey if you want to
be on the show give me a buzz at uh
ninety one it's 1-844-693-3291 eight
four four
six nine three three two nine one or go
to johndaloni.com
ask and don't forget to go pick up
own your past change your future um pick
it up at johnalone.com or
pretty much anywhere but go there all
right uh let's go to greenville south
carolina and talk to d-money david
what's up david
oh not much john glad to be on the
number one health care podcast
not health care man i don't know much
about that that
not health care but mental health there
you go it's the hey
if you say
it long enough it just happens it's
incredible so i'm just going to keep
repeating that
despite most of the evidence to the
contrary what's up man and since you
don't do horse noises anymore
listen the amount of meetings we had
over the horse noises i'm still in
therapy over that but it's good thank
you for remembering where my heart used
to be before kelly took it away
hey so what's up so
my question for you is
how do i heal
from childhood trauma when i don't even
really remember
things from my childhood
um
give me the context for this like
there's a reason why you're calling
what's what's popping up what about the
way you're responding to things in your
current life you don't like
so
i have a bad temper
um don't like myself don't like my job
uh stress with the kids and the wife
um you know life just sucks
what about it sucks man
i mean
just
everything my marital relationship sucks
my relationship with my kids
sucks my relationship with my parents
now sucks
i don't have a relationship with either
of my brothers growing up and
you know there was some major trauma
that that happened to
my older brother
and my younger brother
um
when we were all children and i you know
we had a family motto i swear it was you
know
things are need to know and you don't
need to know because i wasn't told
anything about what happened to either
of them until adulthood okay um
you know my yeah
why does that make you mad right now
um like you you the way you're
describing that is you're put out about
it are they supposed to pull you in a
room as an eight-year-old and be like he
wants to let you know that your brother
was sexually assaulted like
what were you expecting so my brother
went to jail over
what happened to him and then what he
did
you know five or six years later no no
no no no no no no no no
he went to jail because of what he did
right right
um
and
like there was no you know he's just
gone and there's no
you know explanation
of
why he's
not there other than your brother was
assaulted he assaulted somebody else
you know
and
that was pretty much it no
do you need to talk about this with
somebody
you know
the kid that he assaulted
was in the neighborhood you knew him you
weren't really
friends with him but you knew him yeah
um okay so so bring me to right now
that all the things you just mentioned
there's one common denominator
[Music]
what is it uh
so i guess me yeah
so what is it going on in you
that makes you
both believe and act like
you're not worth having a good marriage
you're not worth being a good employee
or you're not worth a job it's worth a
crap
you're not worth having a good
relationship with your brothers or your
kids
what is it about you
that radiates that out everywhere
yeah i
i really don't know you do i mean why
don't you like you
you know the answer to that question and
you've never said it out loud so say it
why don't you like you
you know i i don't know i honestly do
not know
i mean it's it's
i've thought about it i've read your
book and i'm i'm stumbling through it
and i'm just like
you know i really don't know i have this
lack of self-awareness
you know but something but but something
is holding you back from going to get it
right
like i was a bumbling idiot when i got
married and then my wife said these
things have to be different
and i thought a i'm worth more than this
b i value my marriage c
i'm desperately in love with this woman
and i want this to work
and so that left me with two options do
nothing and blow it up or
go learn some new tools
so but something's holding you back and
it has for a long time what is it
i honestly don't know okay
so here's where you find yourself i
don't know
and you're standing there and everything
around you is on fire is that fair
yeah okay
if you happen to be in a home
and you find that it's on fire and you
run to the next room and it's on fire
and you run into the kitchen and it's on
fire
sitting there and trying to figure out
who did this and what happened and
where's the short
is a dangerous game right
right the best thing to do is to get out
of that house and try to figure out how
to put the fire out
it might be that you can do it yourself
with hoses it might be that you need to
call some professionals in to help you
and then when the smoke clears then you
go through and you pick up the pieces
and then you figure out what comes next
okay
so
trying to figure out what happened when
you're a child right now maybe that's
not the best use of your time
i have a feeling that you don't need any
more time thinking
that you've been thinking and talking
and really talking crap to yourself for
a long long long time and getting mad at
other people the way that it was
presented to you
about your brother gives me one little
pinhole of light into the way your home
functioned which is our problems are
because of everybody else
which may have turned you into a 47 year
old or 50 year old are you
47 47 year old
uh
everything i it must be something from
my childhood because i just my family
man go back to the that book you read
and just look at the title
own it this is where i am
and then you have to ask yourself that
terrifying scary question what am i
going to do now
and that's not like uh let's overthink
this let's start changing our actions
right now
so give me a thing you could do right
now that would improve your
relationships
learn how to show love no i don't know
how to show emotion too hard too hard
stop yelling
stop yelling quit yelling at people who
love
i don't even think i'm yelling at like
you're saying you're angry and i'm like
i'm not angry i'm just trying to i'm not
saying i didn't say you were angry
at the beginning of the call you were
like i can hear the anger in your voice
i'm like i don't have any anger in my
voice
but maybe i do and just don't feel it
okay so what you know now is you have a
feeling that tells you one thing and
you've got empirical data that tells you
something else
and so
cool
i'm gonna trust you
does your wife tell you hey um i don't
like the way you're talking to me or i
just wanna she does things that are
gonna go
a little bit to the right because she
doesn't wanna fight you anymore
all the time okay
let that be a cue and say cool i've got
something i got to work on i'm clearly
not seeing it
but i do trust her do you trust her
yeah okay
i
[Music]
if you listen to your body dude it will
let you know
when's the last time you got worked up
and you got angry about something
um
trying to think of one i know there's
been one in the last couple of days i'm
sure
something led to this phone call what
was it
um
just where my wife and i are at
where are you and
i mean we're
so close to divorce it's not funny why
because she
says that she needs emotional intimacy
and i don't even understand what she's
talking about i don't know how to give
it to her
i don't know what it is have you gone
kicking in the doors of a local
therapist saying i need to learn this
now cause i'm about to lose everything
yeah yeah we actually
were in counseling with a therapist and
it
was
i i don't know if he was just trying to
make more money he sucked okay you know
i got an appointment today with another
one there you go man now now you're
talking
and if you lead that with i need to
learn emotional intimacy
most guys i talk to who are struggling
with emotional intimacy
um
have been told since they were very very
young
that didn't hurt suck it up
get up yeah
right yep they've been told since they
were zero that you don't really know how
your body feels i do it didn't hurt get
going
nobody wants to hug you if you hug
somebody it's because you're this or
you're that or you're some kind of
little pants get up
right and so
men are socialized to divorce themselves
from emotions
and then they get married and their
partner says that's all i care about
from you
and then we are standing there going uh
i don't know what to do
right so
dude this is just a set of skills man
it's a set of skills
and if you went to um a mechanic and the
mechanic did a terrible job
you wouldn't have an existential crisis
about it you would just take your car
somewhere else
and you would let your friends know i'm
not gonna use that mechanic anymore let
this be the same thing with your
therapist
is that fair yeah
you gotta learn some skills man
there's there's something beneath the
emotional intimacy though what is it
[Applause]
i really don't know i re i mean i just
you know
why are you about to divorce her
i'm not
i mean i
i don't want to give up but
you know
she's hurt i hurt her in the past i was
an [ __ ] many years ago i know that
okay um
and
you know we we got into an argument
the other day and she brought something
up that
you know to me it's 12 years old it's
it's
you know long time ago and i'm past it
and she's like i just want an apology
and i'm like now if i give you one it's
not heartfelt
why
why would why would that be your
response david what are you protecting
listen you have such a core ego that is
so thin that you are protected you
you've layered shame and you've layered
tough guy and you've layered
uh like a very immature exterior core
ready to bite anybody that comes after
that little kid inside why
were you sexually abused as a kid
i don't think so okay then let it ride
did your parents beat you up as a kid or
neglect you or leave you on the outside
yeah okay
that sucks and they shouldn't have done
that
and
your wife doesn't deserve that exact
same treatment that was done to you does
she
no and your kids don't either do they
no
then learn a few new skills man and
practice the hell out of them
when your body hurts or you find
yourself getting angry or you start to
say something like well i'm not gonna
apologize because it won't even be real
why stop
how is that ever a good answer to the
woman that you love
outside of taking a knee and say or
instead of taking a knee and saying
honey for 12 years i didn't know you're
carrying this around i'm sorry
why wouldn't you mean that
i don't know i guess i just i'm tired of
the past
in my future i'm just
ready to move past it that's fair that
is absolutely fair
and the moment you own it and take
responsibility for what you can
you can be through with it
forgetting about it and ignoring it
doesn't work
carrying around those bricks of anger
about your parents they didn't tell you
something when you were 14. okay here's
the deal they screwed up they should
have sat you down and said your brother
did something terrible and he hurt a kid
in the neighborhood and now he's gone to
jail they should have done that and they
didn't
and now there's a period at the end of
that sentence
and the more you revisit that sentence
and say they should have done this and i
wish that man all you're doing is
gearing your body up for a war that it
can't fight
and so you become the only casualty
over and over again
your parents screwed up man period now
what
see what i'm saying
yeah and i'm telling you this because i
love you man and i'm tired of i
it breaks my heart that you carry this
around with you
your brother did something
evil
and i'm sorry
and something was done to your other
brother
man that ripples through families in a
way that few people could understand i'm
sorry
and now what
what keeps you from
exercising five times a week what keeps
you from going to sleep
what keeps you from asking your wife hey
what does today look like how can i best
love you today
what keeps you from taking each one of
your kids out by themselves and saying
so
the first half of our time together i
haven't done so great but i'm learning
and i'm going to start by saying i'm
sorry i'm going to start by saying i
love you
can i hold you for a minute
yeah i've done that okay
so
no dude
it's not i did that so it's not a
checklist man it's a way of being
[Applause]
do you not want to are you out
no i don't want to be out i just i feel
like i just can't do it
you ah you can
you can
you want to win the championship and you
don't want to go to the weight room
no i don't want to go to the weight room
i will i will not
not deny that but you you know you want
to win you want to be standing up there
holding that big trophy but you don't
want to go on the team retreat and you
don't want to eat right
and you don't want to fill in the bite
and
as a guy who's dealt with my fair share
of trauma i'm telling this from one guy
to another so imagine you and i just
sitting at a table having a beer and i'm
looking at you and i want you to hear me
say this that's immature man
it's time yeah it's time
and yes i can tell you that your wife is
worth it your kids are worth it and all
that stuff but you david
and i hate the fact that no one's ever
told you that
but they haven't and here we are
so what comes next
give me a david identity
i mean honestly david feels like a
loser idiot no no no no who's david
gonna be who's david gonna become
i don't know if david can do it
he can
i've seen it too many times
and i've held too many people's hands in
the black hole
covered nash you can
will you
i want to try
what does that mean
[Applause]
means i'm gonna
tell my wife how sorry i am
tell my kids
again will you tell david
you leave david out of this man
you love your wife and your kids way
more than david and i'm i
you've got to be able to look in the
mirror and see value
i don't
okay
that's fair
but just talking to you for 15 minutes i
tell you you got value
whether you see it or not
and i think if there's one theme of this
call it's that
um
for any number of reasons probably
multiple reasons
your body's feelings your body's alarm
systems that go off when it feels unsafe
or threatened
are out of
tune the either the batteries have worn
down on some of them or they are super
hyper sensitive and they are there to
protect you from fights that you're not
even having
and it's important that you get people
around you that can help be your compass
for a while while those things retune
and all that all
it's a it's a chore to relearn that
stuff make no mistake
but it's not a chore
to just start each day with asking
how can i love you today
and i don't care what you feel like when
she says
man it'd really help if you help with
the dishes and you helped with this and
got kids off to school and it would
really
it would mean a lot to me if you would
run to the gym for 15 minutes and just
work off some of that
it'd mean a lot to me if you'd apply for
a new job because i hate what this job's
doing to you and your first thought is i
don't feel like any of that it's not
even gonna be true to me bro just do it
anyway man
okay okay
but in
i loved
you've heard me talk about the twin
towers right
yep i'd love for you to take your wife
out somewhere for lunch or dinner
tonight and tell her that same thing
that you want to build something new and
you're willing to do what it takes
yeah i don't think she'll believe me
we've actually talked about it that's
fine
does she have a reason to believe you at
this point
no okay
you can tell her that
and then it's going to take a deck of
note cards my brother
go get a deck of note cards for 95 cents
at walgreens or walmart or something
and just write out here's what i'm gonna
do tomorrow
and then here's what i'm gonna do the
next day after that
i wish it was more complicated than that
man and it's not and yes it's going to
be really important if you go talk to a
counselor
because you've got some stuff to unwind
and some skills to learn which is great
but in the meantime
let's just commit to acting let's do it
for 30 days man can you do it for 30
days
yeah
will you make me that promise
i'll make you that promise okay
will you holler back at me in 30 days
after this
i can do that okay
i'm gonna call it a deal you're gonna
haul back at me in 30 minutes i mean uh
30 days after this and we're gonna see
how it is okay and if your wife wants to
call i'd love to talk to her too
here's my deal
you
are the brave name and face of millions
millions of men in in the united states
who are done they're exhausted they're
tired they're just done
and as a guy with a 12 year old little
boy and a six-year-old little girl
i can't have you cash out man i need you
we need you
you need you
[Music]
so i'll walk alongside you
if you keep being brave and keep taking
the next step
you could get yourself a cheap pack of
note cards and say today i'm gonna start
doing stuff different
i'm gonna fake it till i make it i'm
gonna act different i'm gonna do what i
gotta do
to learn this new set of skills so i
don't lose my wife and i don't lose my
kids and i don't repeat the cycle at
some point we stop and say i'm gonna
stare this sucker down
that's courage my brother i'm proud of
you david
30 day challenge here we go we'll be
right back
it seems like everybody is talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com
delony and get the home buyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
the magic of
not live radio
uh
let's see here all right let's go to
nicole
in colorado springs what's up nicole
not much how's it going good good good
good okay that's much much much better
um so what's up
um we my husband and i we are expecting
our second baby early next year awesome
and we are super excited about that but
i am having a lot of anxiety about
sending this baby to daycare
our first baby was a pandemic baby so
there was so much anxiety around that
and we dropped her off at seven weeks
old we were sleeping a couple hours a
night and it was possibly the worst day
of my life
i
don't know if i want to do that again
but i have a different job now and i
love it my career is back on track after
pandemic i love my co-workers i have a
great team flexible schedule like
everything is going so well
and i just i've looked up all the
research and i don't know is there is
there a good time to send a baby to
daycare is daycare really the gulag for
children like uh is there is there a way
i can have it all
that is the magic question that's the
magic question hey i'm laughing i i used
to
so i worked at university i would i
would work in housing and i would help
with move in every year
and um
i would just hug these dads who dropped
their kids off and they would be i mean
these big tough texas dudes and they
would be
boo-hooing and i would just my eyes
would be rolling out of the back of my
head like oh my gosh
and then when hank came along he was
like six weeks or six months or
something and i drove him to like a
tuesday thursday school at some local
church in my community
and i sat in the parking lot and wept
it was like coming to an end man i
remember that day so so much man
um geez louise um
all right
here's what i want to do
i want to avoid
the first half of your question
okay here's why
there's so much competing drama
when it comes to research
yes there's so much competing drama when
it comes to
uh
gender equity discussions in fairness
and what the workplace quote unquote
owes us and
is it best for our kid etc right there's
so much stuff around that right and then
there's the other complicating factor
here's what i think i think that if we
say out loud
ideally
somebody stay a parent stays with that
kid
yeah then
the millions and millions and millions
of people who
can't afford to do that
yeah get thrown into a shame blender
and so instead of having that hard
conversation
everybody just stays away from the
conversation right so here's what i'm
saying yeah it doesn't matter what my
opinion is on that particular part of it
what's more important is your second the
second part of your question
yeah can you have it all
and so hear me say this you know this
and maybe it will help
to have some
just
a male say it out loud maybe that will
help i don't know if it will yeah um
you have entered into an industrial
guilt complex
that is designed intentionally to make
you as a modern woman
who is a mother and an extraordinary
professional
never be able to put both feet on the
ground
no because if you put both feet on the
ground you'll quit buying crap
and you'll quit reading everything
seriously i'm totally serious
the way to keep a mother off kilter and
buying things is to tell her you are
failing your kid
and then you stay home and then to tell
her immediately
you were failing generations of women
who went before you and fought for the
right for you to go dude what are you
doing you're right there's no way to win
yeah and when you're at home you're
looking at the best way to do this i'm
gonna approach it like a career
and then you realize oh there's no way
to you can't win right i mean there's
just so
and then i'm just gonna i'm gonna
approach a career i'm gonna find a great
sitter or i'm gonna find a great nanny
what
and the whole time you're like wow huh
that meeting was more important than my
kid
yes oh this meeting was way more
important than spending an hour with and
then you sit with your kid
and it's the most boring time ever
it's the worst it's the worst
and then at the end of that boring hour
your kid just craps everywhere and you
think
i would have done way better if i was at
work like doing things that contributed
to so right so you know all this stuff
i'm just saying it out loud so you know
you're not crazy
yeah there's not a way to win and answer
your question no you cannot have it all
unless you are a bajillionaire
and most of us are not
are you one of those
we are not we are in a good place like
we could make it like a
we could make it without my income like
we just wouldn't have the extra to save
etc etc okay is that a true statement or
is that a dramatic statement meaning
ah we could make it
if you changed your life up would you
all be just fine
oh yeah a hundred percent like i
always skeptical and people like well we
can't afford it i'm like i want to see
the numbers like we are dedicated like
we could do it there are i i i they are
there i've talked to a bunch of them
that i look at it and say i don't know
how you can stay in this state
unfortunately yeah right 100 100 i have
friends that are that way and it's like
and that's where like you said the guilt
thing it's just it just never stops
ridiculous to do to people who are like
oh my god you don't stay home with your
kid it's like well some people don't
have the option there you go that's
right so
i would have the option i think it's
better for my mental health and my
sanity to at least work part time okay
so i think that's what i'm leaning
towards would it be
like i keep want to go back to the
research so because i've read so many
articles would it be better to find an
in-home daycare provider if we could
versus a daycare center like i love our
daycare and our daughter has
a great routine i can always count on
them to be there like she's so smart i
think i
i don't have any of that data in front
of me okay just been off top of my head
i know how important routine in
environment is
i also know how important stimulation
and social engagement is
and so i can flip a coin on that one
right now now somebody may send me and
if it's out there feel free to email it
to me um the last literature i read
um
and i don't even know when the study was
published and i don't even know the
efficacy of the study had some
correlation between moms who stay at
home and like
test scores when the kid was in 10th
grade or something like that yeah and so
um fine fair cool
um
i think it's gonna cut
oh now you're getting a whole other
soapbox here's the deal i know i know
we more data is not a good antidote to
anxiety
okay
i know it is i know it is you are going
to article yourself to death
and never truly ask yourself what do i
want to do
and then here's the scariest thing and
we are not taught this skill in our
modern world
live with the consequences of our
choices
yeah
and so
at some point you're going to put the
articles down stop taking your
girlfriends out the coffee and saying
okay what do you think how did it work
for you got to stop all that you have to
quit going on walks with your husband at
night going but i think and i don't know
and he's just like i don't just pick
something right
exactly um at some point you're gonna
have to exhale and say
what i want counts
i am a good mom
and i'm a really good employee
here's what i think is best for this
particular season right now
and i'm going to give it a shot for six
months
and if it's an absolute disaster
great i got some more data
and which you happen to just love love
loved just like me by the way and i'm
then gonna move on and i'm gonna go back
to work full-time and it's gonna hurt
but it's right or i'm gonna stay at home
full-time and it's gonna hurt and it's
right or i'm gonna muddle through it and
i'm gonna work part-time
it's
you're making a choice right this second
that is not a forever choice
it's the best choice to make right now
for you your husband your family these
kids i mean you know what i mean
yeah and so take the burden off of uh if
i do this one thing wrong it's all it's
not
it's not
is that fair
yeah that little kid's gonna love you
who told you that what you want doesn't
count
oh it's it's something my therapist and
i've been working on for quite a while
now
[Music]
so what does your what does your
therapist think you should do
generally we've just gotten better about
me getting clear about what i want okay
and then telling the people close to me
what i want that includes like my
parents
why why would you tell them why'd you
tell anybody in the world other than
your husband
um because some of the um decisions like
would involve my parents and so like if
we have expectations they're like these
are the needs that i need you to meet or
these are like our boundaries those are
the things that i would need to tell
them
can i save you the next 20 years of
sadness and guilt and shame and all that
your parents don't get a vote
take them out of the i take them out of
your voting machine
okay and that one hurt because we've
been doing that for a while i know take
them out they don't get a vote
because parents
there's a lot that goes into that and
you'll learn this
as you have your own kids but
they
have different reasons for making
different decisions
and you can love them and honor them and
listen
and then you got to do what's best for
you and your husband and they don't get
a vote
yeah
you know what i mean
you may invite them into a certain
situation or a certain moment or a
certain conversation and which is
wonderful and great but at the end of
the day you and your husband make this
call
and then you can let them know hey
here's what we're gonna do we'd love you
to be involved here and then they get to
make grown-up decisions and say we're
not gonna be a part of that and that's
gonna hurt and sting and be sad and all
that stuff and then we're gonna move on
with their lives
yeah right
will you say it out loud they don't get
a vote
they don't get a vote
i'm working on canceling the inner
dialogue too
that i grew up with
daycare is for bad mom and it's morally
superior to home with your kid no matter
what it cost you right
i'm sorry you're carrying that stuff
around
thank
you those stories you were born into and
the stories people told you because
those stories become the ones you tell
yourself right
yeah yeah
so here's the deal those stories were
told to you and they have a period at
the end of them
right
those stories were told they happened
now you can spend a whole bunch of
energy trying to go back and edit those
sentences or you can
do the one thing that your two little
kids and your husband are desperate for
you to do which is to spend your energy
writing new sentences
here's what comes here's what comes next
is that cool
that's cool
um for whatever it's worth i talked to a
lot of folks behind closed doors who are
struggling and
um
it's not rare that i talk to a parent
that um
we have to i have to report we have to
call we have to get involved with and so
hear me say this your two kids are
really lucky to have you
thank you real lucky
now go make the right choice and don't
screw this up nicole
no pressure
no pressure look hey give yourself six
months okay
okay give yourself six months and say
i'm gonna work part-time i'm gonna work
from home for six months and then i'm
gonna
re-re-imagine it
um my friend eva who's a writer who's
brilliant um she worked with me for the
last couple years
she was one of the few people in what i
would call in my trust circle i would
write a talk and that she would say john
this isn't funny this is dumb like you
think this is so dramatic it's not it's
over it's just annoying
um she was uh an absolute professional
gift and then she had baby number four
and
um she came back rocking and rolling
were on to the next
and then she just went home
she had this time
and it didn't make leaving an awesome
work environment um easy
no and this is the season she's chosen
and she's gonna do other things and work
from home all that to say but see what
i'm saying like
every mom's got to make a different call
my wife has gone through various
variations and right now she's in a
season i don't expect it to last that
way forever none of us do it's just the
season right now
and sometimes it's been full time and
sometimes it's 100 stay at home it's
just been a fluctuation in in time and
place and season
the greatest gift you can give nicole is
some grace
you're mean to nicole stop
if hey if your husband
was out like at a tj maxx cause let's be
honest that's where he shops i can
already tell if he's hanging out at t.j
maxx
and he heard somebody talk to his wife
the way you do he'd go to jail
he could go to jail right
right don't talk to his wife like that
he wouldn't marry someone who's a
goofball
you know what i mean
yeah
don't talk to your kid's mom that way
yeah
give nicole some grace and give nicole
some trust
okay and i know those are hard you gotta
practice those things because they're
tough those are hard
you gotta practice we're getting better
i know but listen
um and you can tell your counselor i
said this
a lot of my colleagues in the mental
health profession do a lot of thinking
and talking about thinking
at some point you got to start doing and
then
practicing okay yeah
yeah
so make a call and sit with it for a few
days are you gonna quit your job
no
you're not
no okay
are you gonna be 100 full-time
stay-at-home mom no ta-da
look at that
are you gonna work full-time or
part-time
i think part-time
ta-da
here's what's beautiful about that you
nicole are gonna disappoint everybody
so great
you can disappoint your parents you're
gonna disappoint your workplace you're
gonna disappoint everybody except for
the four people that actually matters
for
true right
right congratulations nicole
thank you yeah i mean i mean honestly
you're you're a free woman
congratulations
and put a note on the calendar
six months from the day your baby's born
and say we're gonna revisit this we're
gonna revisit this in month five and
that gives us about 30 days to talk
about how's it going how do we feel
um how's our finances house like we're
in an incredibly fortunate position
right now financially um and
then we'll reimagine it and go from
there
low pressure
low pressure
and everybody listening um i will do
this i'll make the commitment to get
into that scholarship i do get that
question um with some regularity and so
i'll dig into it and i'll all i'm not
afraid of the conversation about it um i
don't want to wade into
a bunch of social drama around the
science of it around the shame of it
around what might be optimal versus what
people have to do to survive
right and there's just all that gets
dumped into a big bucket and then people
just want to throw grenades and i'm not
i'm not interested in that
but i will dig into it um
and to all you moms out there i'm sorry
that we've created a world
that is focused solely on making you
feel guilty so you buy stuff
to feel a little bit less guilty
my hope and prayer and dream for you
guys is y'all
we rally around and create a world where
y'all can
feel free to trust yourselves
and to listen to yourselves and to act
on that and then to say that
i tried that i didn't like him and try
something else and then we celebrate
that and we don't go told you
and
soon to be grandma and grandpa
your guilt doesn't help
let's just dial it back about 40 or 50
we'll be right back
hey deloney here and i've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp i've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years
when i was spinning out like a decade
ago with wild anxiety i had a moment
that light bulb moment
that i knew i had to do something
different i knew i had to change
something probably a lot of somethings
right but i found myself without the
tools for taking the next step and when
you're facing problems or challenges in
life it's way too easy to get stuck in
that anxious spiral of doom i've been
there but when you learn how to stop
that cycle and start taking ownership of
your life that's when you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why i love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
if you're ready to get the tools that
you need to deal with the curve balls
life's thrown at you therapy can help
visit betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
chris in gainesville florida what's up
chris
uh not too much dr john it's an honor to
speak with you thank you for taking my
call uh it's an honor to talk to you
brother what's up man
uh so i'll be brief uh give you a little
background and then i guess we can uh
go where the conversation leads uh but
uh so over time uh my relationship with
my mom has degraded to the point that i
no longer wish to have a relationship
with her how old are you um
i'm 40. 40. okay how old is she
uh she is 70. okay cool thanks man
oh uh so i feel that as the years have
gone on that my family and i are less
and less of a priority
but what stops me is she's still my mom
um i
but even when when we travel to go back
home or even when i see her name come up
on a phone call i instantly gain anxiety
and it's to a point to it's not
crippling but it's to a point to where i
i feel i'm uncomfortable even afterwards
or even leading up to travel
um so i've read your book um own your
past change future and
um this brick has been in my backpack
for years um
but given given the nature of who it is
i i need some help learning how to set
it down and let it go cool man um not
really man i appreciate that call yeah
you are not alone my brother in that one
so thanks for um having the courage to
reach out
um
what did your mom do
uh so she's not retired what did she do
to you
so what does she do to you
um so i am i'm an active duty service
member so unfortunately my family is an
army rat family in tow so we've we've
moved all around the country and we
still continue to
uh but for the longest time wait a
minute wait a minute what do you mean
unfortunately
well so uh it's a it's a path that i
chose and my family uh my family's been
along for the ride and they have been
extremely supportive through through the
whole uh through the whole ordeal
um did you tell your wife you were going
to work at home depot and then suddenly
you came home and you're like surprised
i enlisted
uh so no a funny story with uh with how
i met my wife uh not even two months
after my deployment to iraq and uh she
was
she was on board with a soldier from
right then and there so no it wasn't a
surprise so she chose you too
she did so she chose this life
she did and your kids are gonna get to
see all parts of the country in the
world and meet all kinds of new people
and learn from different adults and
children their own age
oh they are
that's incredible
no more ever sing unfortunately
cool yes sir yes i grew up in the same
home in the same town on the same street
in the same place and i had a great
childhood
and it's also terrifying for me to be
away from my house
right which is a makes it tough to live
in a modern world so i liked being
stable i also wish man i'd gotten some
opportunities to go out and see some
stuff
so it's gonna be six months in another
your kids are lucky to have you
cool
yes okay all right back to it sorry for
the interruption
oh no no problem at all okay so what
what what is why does your mom make you
anxious what does she do man
so it stemmed from i i would say even
even back when when i was in college uh
so we uh so some background on that so
my
my mother and father divorced after 40
years just a few years back
um but in reality even
even myself and my siblings we thought
if it was going to happen it should have
happened 20 years ago
so we were not a close-knit family that
drifted apart i think we've kind of been
uh we've kind of just had this dynamic
for years uh to the extent to where
like i i just i never enjoyed going home
my my sister graduated from college and
she had an apartment and her
relationship went south and she moved
back home at 25 and is still there today
so
what made you uncomfortable when you
went back people whining and complaining
about everything are they poking at you
are they saying man you're getting fat
or why do you have a beard or you never
even come around anymore ooh goody two
like what is it what was it about the
things that you showed up to
so it was always for holidays but for
the longest time
me and my family we lived 45 minutes
away
but my family only made it a priority to
come over on holidays
but
i guess it's a social media to me has
just been like a terrible enabler as
well because on social media
my mom would would then decide to post
stuff that oh i miss my grandkids or i
miss my family so much but
she doesn't call for birthdays um she
will post on facebook or even even as
her own son i would get a text on my
birthday you know at 10 p.m at night
because i think she may have seen
something on social media to remember
that oh it's it's my son's birthday yeah
so
before your parents got divorced you
mentioned about college take me back to
middle school
what was middle school like in your
house
um middle school wasn't uh it wasn't too
bad um when i was what does that mean
so around that time
my brother was in high school and i so
with me being in middle school
i guess so there was a significant
family event my uh my brother was in a
terrible car accident that put him in
the hospital for quite some time
so that shifted the family dynamic a
little bit but
my dad has always kind of been distant
he's an outdoorsy person my mom wasn't
um so like my dad was he was more of a
weekend dad because he would uh
he would stay he would probably stay out
on the farm in the cabin
through the week because that's what he
enjoyed to do but
then we we got together on the weekends
and after your brother's accident did
mom
dial up the anxiety in the house
um a little bit and it took a while to
figure that out
so
my brother passed away back in 2009 from
an accidental overdose
and my mom couldn't handle it we all
struggled pretty hard but it was only
then when we learned because
my mom almost died of a
prescription pill overdose
that she had battled with uh with
prescription meds ever since my brother
was in an accident in the 90s
so just to just for the sake of brevity
you've probably heard this but if you
haven't um
i'll say it anyway
trauma can be affirmative it can be a
thing that somebody does to you
it can also be a thing that somebody
kept from you that they should have
given you
and connection with an adult is oxygen
for a child
and so nobody put their hands around
your throat but you were suffocated as a
kid
and living with an addict
is like trying to hug a ghost you see
them and every time you try to hold on
tight your hands go right through them
right they're present with you but
they're not there
and for a kid
especially with pills
especially with pills
kids go crazy
because they see that person in front of
them that they're supposed to love
and that person doesn't respond in a in
a way that
makes sense to a little kid's body and i
say little kid i'm talking about through
high school
and so it doesn't surprise me the least
bit and you and i could probably sit
down dude and grab a drink and just talk
all the way through it but man it
doesn't surprise me for a little bit
that that family system sets your body's
alarms off that we're not safe here
this isn't a smart place for us to be
right
right
and
i want you to hold that tension with
this thing i'm about to tell you okay it
could be
that you got a mom with a lot of guilt
and a lot of shame
who looks at the world this way
my little boy left me
he had to get out of here and i
understand it so he went to the military
to get away from me
and then he married somebody who was all
in on the military now they move around
every year and i don't want to bother
them
so i'm just gonna i miss them like
bloody hell and i love them but i'm just
gonna post about it i'm not even gonna
reach out
i don't want to bother them i've done
enough damage for one lifetime
i'm giving her a ton of grace
when i do that okay
here's why i'm telling you that
it doesn't matter
what matters is this
you don't like who you become in the
presence of certain people you don't
like how your body responds you don't
like the way that it makes you short
around your family you don't like the
way that your kids get dragged through
your attention as you're packing up to
go to a place you don't even want to be
taking them right all that works
together
so i want you to relax and drop your
shoulders and trust chris
i believe deeply that we need to respect
our parents even when they haven't been
good to us but that doesn't me that
means i'm gonna treat you with dignity
and kindness
sometimes the most dignified thing i can
do if you're an abusive parent is not
talk to you
okay
you're holding on to a fantasy
that you either need to
get right smack in the middle of or you
need to let go
is that fair you're holding on to a
fantasy that your mom is suddenly going
to loop back around and become this
incredible grandmother and it's going to
become a party again maybe even your
parents will get back together like you
know what i mean that whole line
and there's something heartbreaking like
what is it about my kids you even
calling their birthday
like what did they do right you know
what i mean
yeah
so either you get in a car and go drive
to her house and say i miss my mom
and we had a terrible childhood
and i want to rebuild this relationship
starting today and i'm going first
i moved all over the world and i miss
you and i hope you didn't take that
personal that it was something against
you
something i wanted to do and um i'm a
service oriented guy you raised me that
way
i want to recreate this thing but here's
my boundaries for it you can do that
and if you do it golly chris it's a risk
man because she could say no
she could blame you for everything
whatever or she might weep and say i'm
so glad my boy came home that could
happen the other one could be man give
yourself some grace and some peace and
set it down
say man it would have been awesome to
have a grandma like this that was all in
on her kids that would come that drive
that 45 minute drive so much that we had
the teller quick coming over because
you're here all the time
and that's not the grandma my kids got
and this is the reality that i find
myself in
which one of those sounds like a better
option
the second one
feel like you need to let it go
i do
um
yeah so and that's the that's the
background so like me and my wife are
like the perfect dynamic um that were
opposites and
i've i've battled with it for a while um
and and my wife's family are super
close-knit um like they
uh like her and her sister talk every
single day multiple times a day like she
talks to her mom all the time and and i
realize that so i i did come to reality
that i realized that
um i'm not i'm not asking for my mom to
be her mom i know but hold on that's
where i struggle but it'd be awesome if
she was right it would okay it would
when you acknowledge that you
immediately will hit a water slide down
into
[Music]
and you've been there before as a
serviceman in that black hole of grief
like
damn it my mom should show up and see
her grandkids and want be proud of me
and she won't say those words that's
grief
i wanted this to be this way and here's
what it actually is
and if you'll sit there for a minute
and probably go one step further and
write that
11 or 12 year old chris a letter
letting him know i'm sorry
this you shouldn't have been dragged
through this sorry brother got hurt i'm
sorry my dad he actually divorced mom 30
years ago they started fighting 20 years
ago and then they finalized it 10 years
ago
sorry that mom was an addict and wasn't
there for you you deserve better than
that you got to connect with that kid
let him know um it's time for him to go
run and play
because he's 11.
he doesn't need to be holding a
household together at that age
because you're still trying to hold it
all together now dude
is it fair
it is it is very fair
i'm sorry man
geez
how old are your kids
uh so one is 13 and the other one turned
seven in two months they're awesome
they're amazing they are the i couldn't
have asked for better kids and it makes
no sense that somebody wouldn't want to
hang out with them does it
none whatsoever okay
they're not hanging out
with y'all
because they're working through things
it's not because there's a problem with
you
okay
okay
i hate that
i hate that
um at some point they come back around
that's my guess
but that day is not today
um
we're coming up on a couple of months
out from the holiday season
this may be a great year to practice
and proactively let everybody know hey
this particular holiday season we're
going to be traveling somewhere else or
we're gonna be staying at home this year
and so
um
we're gonna send grandma a card kids
we're gonna write this and send it and
then i'm gonna put that to rest
well
and then maybe if i could if i could
interject then another question so i
think where the guilt comes from is so
obviously um so they're back in the
midwest um with where i met my wife
that's where the guilt comes in about
visiting
is that her in like so my in-laws my
wife's parents live six miles
from my mom okay and so when we go home
that's normally where i feel i get
guilted into going um because
that i feel that her family will travel
to come see their grandkids
but
it seems like we only become a priority
and we're expected to visit only when we
make that effort to go all the way home
so you got two choices man you cannot go
and say sorry guys i won't be able to
make it this year
or you can go and
well i guess you got three choices you
can do that say sorry we're not able to
make it this year and by the way dude
they have cashed out their vote
they have chosen to not participate in
the functioning of this family
it's like people who don't vote and they
yell about the president you don't get
to do that if you don't play
right and so right they don't get a vote
they can yell real loud and it's
annoying and it hurts but they don't get
a vote that's one number two you can go
just try to make the fantasy come true
and meet all of their needs which you
know is a moving it's a moving finish
line you can never get to the end of
that line because it always moves
because as soon as you've been there six
hours and you actually had a good visit
someone's gonna say how come you're
never coming around anymore you too good
for us and then oh gosh we're right back
where we started right
the third thing is you can go visit her
family and have a wonderful holiday and
tell your family i will be available for
lunch on this day
if y'all would like to have lunch i
would love to be there
it will be there from 12 to 3.
and those are that's just called
boundaries
and if they say well we can't make it
because timmy's got a fishing tournament
and billy's going to be a that's great
what they are doing is they are choosing
not to be with you
and that hurts especially they're going
to blame you for it
right
right but that's one of three options
and here's the deal
make peace with the choice man
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
wrong but i do know this i trust you
to do what's right for your family
so do what's right for them
do what's right for you
and be at peace man
you're not gonna let me say it this way
you're not gonna be able to think
yourself into the right action you're
gonna have to do something
and at the end of this holiday season if
you choose to not go you choose to go
all the way to the midwest hang out with
her family and not go see your family
you'll know if that was right
you'll know
and then next year you have some more
data and you can make a different choice
or you go
you do know this you know that traveling
down there and doing it makes you feel
like a prostitute right
yes
yeah so you got that piece of data try
something else is that fair
it's fair yes yeah cool
ta-da i should have led with that uh
try something else man
um
let me see it this way
you're
you and your family are worth having a
good holiday season
and you can love your mom and respect
her
and not let her participate in bringing
your holiday season down
that doesn't mean you love her less it
doesn't mean you're disrespecting her
that doesn't mean whatever this respect
doesn't mean you have to do whatever
somebody else says even to your family's
detriment
it doesn't
and you have to grieve the fact that you
wish your mother was something that she
has chosen to not be and that hurts and
i'm sorry and same with your dad and
sing with your brothers
but i will say this i'm grateful for you
i'm grateful for the sacrifice of your
family
and i trust you
so you should trust you we'll be right
back
hey delonay here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show man
that's a hard show i guess i feel like
all these shows are hard
listen if you just bought a puppy and
you want to cut right in and talk about
it give us a shout
if you sign it dog dad
you're not on the show absolutely no
chance
no
um
the song of the day you know what i love
the cure i love them i love them i love
them robert smith and the gang
and it's one of my favorite songs ever
the song is called friday i'm in love
and it goes like this
i don't care if monday's blue and
tuesday's gray and wednesday too
thursday i don't care about you
it's friday i'm in love
and monday you can fall apart tuesday
wednesday break my heart thursday
doesn't even start
it's friday i'm in love saturday wait
sunday it always comes too late but
friday
never hesitate
and i don't care if monday's black
tuesday wednesday heart attack thursday
never looking back it's friday i'm in
love
[Music]
have a good friday everybody
stay in school don't do drugs